this is chroma an ancient legend master
of the elements adaptable to any combat
scenario he reigns supreme over the
battlefield cromoz abilities adapt to
his energy color drastically modifying
their effects spectral scream exhales
deadly elemental breath forgoing normal
weapon use while active elemental ward
surrounds nearby allies with a
reflective elemental shields fire gives
additional health and adds a flame aura
that deals additional damage electricity
provides additional shields while
storing some incoming damage discharging
upon nearby enemies poison adds a
stamina boost while also providing an
aura that has a chance to poison nearby
enemies ice applies additional armor as
well as an ice shield that reflects
incoming fire inflicting some damage to
enemies vex armor converts any shield
damage taken into an armor increase and
any health loss into a limited damage
increase perfect for meeting the charge
into battle free yourself 1000 effigy
sheds chromis Pelt which hovers in the
air defending against enemies with
elemental attacks while active chroma
will gain speed but loses a portion of
his armor all of chromosomal --'tis are
benefited by increased strength while
spectral scream an elemental ward become
more effective with added range duration
complements elemental ward and vex armor
when all the land is in ruins ten of
the chroma will remain